try let's try something let's try
something I don't
know
two and we'll just project don't worry
about the Thro hey
whatever if he falls he
falls
[Music]
okay
try
for picking picking technique is uh by
our definition is fear any functioning
of the ego tripartite mind is fear what
is fear the functioning of the ego
tripartite mind okay so picking
techniques is the functioning of the ego
tripartite mind it is a fear response
okay so instead you're going to
feel the same thing you felt so I'm
going to internally let him press on me
until he he gives me his Center you see
and then when I want then I'll coook you
out you understand so I'm not going to
go I let him press he pushes on me I'll
feel where it is it's right here you
feel it okay and so that's the one that
I
use same thing
I'm wait for him to press on me there it
is right there then these are the two
that I
use it just is
[Music]
smooth
feel
you
here
okay try it
[Music]
again
okay not
bad but you have you have uh a gaming
that happens from the drill and the
drill is that the UK keeps pushing okay
so as you come around here you see I'm
not really in your and then you push and
then I can see that instead right at
[Music]
contact Stu so I do that I do I in your
Center but I yield B but not coming out
of your Center
okay contact in
in in in look you see but you're are
going to
yield but I'm in look you see now go
this
way
good right you
better you better in
okay
ground the back
foot okay so you have this DST
alchemical component to
training its main objective is to
reconcile the two minds its main
objective is a means to the spiritual
maturity of the reconciled two
minds what we are going to do now in
applying
Kaza in inside Gaza I guess it doesn't
have to be a Kon but
Naga applying naga in a GU
situation what I'm going to do is that
Dow alchemical
aspect right in the middle of my naaza
so for example I I here and you can see
the
projection but there's also that
energetic component where I'm not just
yielding we're
stuck as just at a certain point i w
I'll project it out do you understand
okay so we're going to take that the
mechanism of that alchemical aspect and
that's the same thing in your keyho
horn you understand you're not going to
do something you're not going to do
something
different just touching different parts
in here so same thing home I'm in
home so we'll do that tension n
again I internally let him give me his
Center but internally yielding I
externally yield and now I'm adhering to
his body now I have his
body and I enter with his body and
project the body lock I project his body
I don't try to accelerate him I do the
same
exact hope projection on his
body do a lot of other
technique feel
not okay any CQ projection is c n okay
but any other Naga should also be k n
okay here we
go
don't just accelerate him yes there's a
projection so that same feeling should
be in the Kyo you just tried to do
[Music]
before so H hey
here here's
the do you think okay I did cook you for
I don't I don't just lean you back and
accelerate the same
[Music]
connection
you see the same projecting Force
okay different isn't that that's all
external I make my connection
[Music]
oh still there throw it's still a
projection on the
hand
okay try it
again so the outer for de exterior form
is not important the exterior form could
be anything it could even be nothing
that was the first the earlier point I
made it could be nothing you don't have
to do a martial art okay so uh in that
in that same way that it could be it
could be from The pugilistic Stance I'm
still going to hit him with that same
energetic aspect yeah got it I'm not
just going to start swinging my fist
through the air and get some hip
rotation and things like that okay so
even on the techniques that
look like they're momentum ones they're
not just like that technique that pulled
you off that base do you see whoa okay
so you I saw you do this one you see
you're here like that right and it looks
like you're just going to pull this you
understand not so I'll show you I'll
show you the pulling one boom
here and you'll
see
Stu Bo
throw holding one
no not here there it
is you see that difference okay so take
tet looks like I'm going like
this but you know I'm not as
the say thing this one looks like I'm
going like
[Music]
this you know I'm
not okay you see the difference okay
find the
CBE regardless of the direction if the
form itself does not count the direction
does not count try it
again
[Music]
for
bro you don't have connection right
you're just moving
[Music]
backwards and then don't just accelerate
them got to ground the back foot you got
to relax you got to release you bring
the you're bringing the Yang aspect into
you you need it to function you can't
resist
it
heyar
much so uh here been doing the K quite a
b
here there right there so look go his
head you
see don't put it all in his head and
then
right even if you don't grab it it
doesn't matter you still project up his
but you see
that you feel like yes okay so how can
you get there not
important but here's a contact point so
use
it on you it's no different you see
that's a contact point you see that oh
not
here
look you
see there's a contact point you see not
here here you feel okay and then not
here contact Point
project so just like if you're
doing your techniques right I don't want
you I don't want to
see this external
thing
okay same here if you're going to
practice maybe don't
complete the arm
movement do you understand reduce the
arm
movement s
here
same thing tension on instead
of here maybe reduce it a
little get it so your kid see if you're
doing it or not okay let's try
me
so
um that's external and you're I'm
stronger than
you I'm just throwing it around and you
know don't lay down on the ground too
long with your back you know what I mean
[Music]
okay
that's thei all right so what is it the
kazushi is
this when you push and I
yield until you let basic basically I'm
not touching your Center but by yielding
then I have your
Center that's
kazushi so
even when we're
here there we
are I am in control you're not tilted
you see and your line of gravity is not
outside your base of support
but let's do this you if you go you can
let go if you
want
but you didn't want to did you because
what did you
feel you're going to feel that yeah you
got it I'm going to punch the out
of you do you understand so what do you
do
instead I have a center you understand
he started like go I don't know if you
can see it but he can feel my ill
will coming at him you don't know that's
position not the tilting I use that to
tilt you do you understand so the
tilting is an
external consequence of kazushi which is
where I touch your Center by non-
contesting the young aspect of your
prescribed pressure okay so you're going
to do that technique I had to do
this that's what I have you feel it
again I going move
you you want to let go let go if you
want you see so I can move you so same
thing moving you
moving still here pay attention right do
you want to move that arm off of me noce
you see that so I'm controlling so as
you get up I yield to that I'll L you up
but you can see that I still have that
Center so I let you
up see and creates openings but it comes
from controlling the center which comes
from non- contesting the young
aspect do you understand okay so think
of that as cons
not the external there is an external
component but there is an internal
component that is concentric with
it okay okay if you just have the outer
shell it won't work it's not it's not
it okay just like what I was trying to
show you in this chaza is it really is
all C
DOA you see Alla
Isa
Alla you see so you shouldn't change it
you shouldn't get out of the way and
then they fall
into your hole you created or you bend
them backwards and so they fall or you
accelerate them and it's easier for them
to just roll than try to run and get
their base under them that's not it
okay little bit more